We forgot to lock the perp in again...
Ah, the chief's gonna have our badges for this one...
..I wont tell if you don't.
[huffing]
Credit TheReacher24 with help of the credits!!!
[controlled breathing]
Bonnie: Okay, this is the place!
"What about Springtrap back at the office?"
Chica: What if he escapes out into the streets?!
Nate: Look, you guys focus on getting inside... I'll handle Springtrap.
[electronic beep]
(Robot voice): Hi
Okay buddy.  Let's keep him distracted.
[something hits wall]
[Mark hollers, startled]
[voice in distance]
[Mark breathes anxiously]
Foxy: Yaarrrgh
[Mark screams]
[thud, Foxy grunts]
Chica: Foxy, are you okay?!
[Foxy stammers]
Nate: There you are.
Would you kindly follow me?
[bb.exe beeping]
[Springtrap growling]
Is it true? Are they back? Am I going mad?
One mistake's all it takes, and this may go bad!
No one's there!
No one-is somebody there?
Four more hours left for me to stall!
Why's that furbag sneaking down the hall?
No one's there
Someone's there
Wish I could say someone's/no-one's there!
Chica: Hi there!
Okay good talk.
I'll Fill The Void With Noise...
Just Focus On Me!
Somethings Breathing Out Beyond The Door!
Hey It's Me I Swear We Met Before...
I dont care.
No one's there!
Where'd Foxy go?
He's In There!
Hurry Guys I Think Im Losing Ground!
Why's my closet making pirate sounds?
Foxy: Yarrrrr!!!
[Mark screams]
Please Come Save Us!
Springtrap's Gone Insane!
Does This Help Explain?
Stay Back!
Huh, I Guess It Didnt
Nate: OH!
(End Of Singing)
That's not good.
[BB.exe shuts down]
Nate: NO NO NO NO COME ON! COME ON!
Freddy: Maybe we should just calm down and sing a special song togeth-
Mark: SHUT UP BEAR.
Bonnie: Okay just take it easy.
Chica: Can you please put down the knife?
Mark: Don't come any closer or I'l- I'll carve out his stuffing and wear his skin like a suit!!!
Bonnie: Well, now he's just being ridiculous.
Nate: pleeeaaaaase get up.
Mark: Y-You're not taking me alive!!!
Bonnie: Uh, we're not taking you at all.
Chica: We aren't here to hurt you!
Mark: Get away from me I-I'll do it, I swear!!!
Freddy: Please don't kill me!
Nate: I'd be careful with that knife.
That's Freddy Fazbear.  He holds a special place in the hearts of children, soooooo...
you should show him a little respect.
Mark: You have the Night Shift...?
Are you with THEM?!?!
Nate: [sarcastically]  No I'm the Uber Driver for a bunch of puppets.
Mark: What do you want?
Chica: YOUR HELP
Freddy: THERE'S A KILLER ANMATRONICS ON THE LOSE AT FREDDY FAZBEAR'S!!!
Nate: We'd go to the police, but... they'd probably think we're crazy.
Bonnie: Sound familiar?
Mark: O-okay wait, hang on a second.
Even if I was to believe that you TALKING robots didn't want to kill me,
and even if I was willing to go back to FREDDY FAZBEAR'S -- which I'm NOT--
What do I get out of this?
Psychological damage?
Uh, a horrible gruesome death?
25 years to life with a cellmate named BUFFALO-FRICKIN-BILL!!!!!
[Foxy emits ponderous grunt]
Nate: Uh I don't know. Proving you didn't lie to the police would be pretty cool.
Mark: Fine.
Freddy: HURRAY!!!
Mark: Don't touch me.
Nate: Freddy's opens in a few hours. We should lay low until everyone leaves for the night.
Bonnie: Who wants to listen to some awesome tunes?
Radio: BABY I LOVE YOU ( BABY I) OOOOOO
YOU'RE SO FIIIIIINE
Mark: SHUT THAT OFF OR I WILL KILL YOU.
*SCREACH*
Freddy: There's a killer animatronic, and he's filled with poop, and I don't like him,
and he's gross.
[ drowning sounds]
Mark: Hey guys, thanks so much for watching.
If you enjoyed this video, there's actually another night
and many previous nights to watch.
All the links are in the description below
and annotations all around my face.
THANK YOU, Random Encounters.  THANK YOU, Natewantstobattle
THANK YOU, everyone who is behind the scenes as well
And thank you for watching. I'll be here [breaths in air] RELAXING.